all right joining us now is one of the
few who questioned dr fauci's expertise
and motives
as early as we did kentucky senator rand
paul senator
you are now calling for the firing of
anthony fauci
uh what can you do in the senate
to get more answers than the ones that
we have from these emails which are
still redacted
you know i think we've had a sea change
of opinion everybody
left of center was saying this was a
conspiracy no way could it have happened
in the wuhan lab
now we've been dr falchi saying that we
should investigate it
but the emails paint a disturbing
picture a disturbing picture of dr
fauci from the very beginning worrying
that he had been funding gain of
function research
and he knows it to this day but hasn't
admitted we have to get
democrat counterparts that will actually
use the committee hearings
to investigate this but so far it's been
such a partisan
support for dr fauci that he can do no
wrong
but really there's a lot of evidence
that he has a great deal of conflict of
interest
and that if it turns out this virus came
from the wuhan lab which it looks like
it did
that there's a great deal of culpability
in that he was a big supporter of the
funding
but he also was a big supporters to this
day of saying we can trust the chinese
on this
we can trust the chinese scientists and
i think that's quite naive and
really should preclude him from the
position that he's in
and referencing the point you just made
senator the emails
they show that fauci was scrambling
in those early days of the pandemic
to find out the links between the nih
funded gain of function research and
cova now here's how one of his
nih underlings responded to this email
about a 2015 gain of function study
that was co-authored by the wuhan
institute of virology's bat lady
and he said the paper you sent me says
the experiments were performed
before the gain of function pause
but have since been reviewed and
approved by nih not sure
what this means since emily is sure that
no coronavirus work has gone through the
p3
framework explain that senator why is
that so
significant here here's laura what makes
it worse
two weeks ago in committee hearing he
said they did not fund
any gain of function research i quoted
that specific paper
right so the very paper that he puts in
the email he says oh my goodness we need
to read this paper because
we looks like we are actually funding
gain of function research
which is where we juice up these viruses
take them from animals and
infect them into humans he's admitting
that to his underling he's worried about
this
in february of last year but only two
weeks ago he tells me
oh it wasn't gain of function research
but in his email in the subject line he
says
gain of function research he was
admitting it to his private underlings
seven eight nine months ago i mean could
there be
criminal culpability here given given
the
repeated uh uh failures
of dr fauci who is basically in charge
of our
much of our messaging on this and and
advice on this
could there be criminal culpability here
a fraud or
ongoing collaboration with the chinese
when
when he was making excuses for them
at the very least there's moral
culpability in the research done by the
bat scientist in wuhan
she gives him credit she lists the exact
nih
grant with a 10 numeral disclaimer or id
number
listing the money and thanking the nih
for the money it's clearly gained a
function
there are several scientists who are in
this field cellular biologists
they all say that taking a sars back a
sars virus
and adding an s protein to it to make it
infect human cells
that is the very definition of gain of
function it's very dangerous we
shouldn't be doing it here
or there but dr fauci has denied it to
this day
but the private emails show that he was
acknowledging
that it was gain of function nobody was
questioning it
the scientific community needs to look
at this because he hides behind this
veil of the lab coat that nobody can
question him
yeah well i believe and by looking at
the evidence that it absolutely was gain
of function research
and he was funding it and to this day
he's still saying he would do it again
because he trusts the chinese zionist
well one of those emails obtained by
buzzfeed senator
was from peter dashock of the eco health
alliance so he was the one pushing this
and doing this research and that was
funded by nih
uh in wuhan so he wrote to fouchy on
april 18 2020
i just wanted to say a personal thank
you for publicly standing up
and stating that the scientific evidence
supports
a natural origin for coven 19.
not a lab release from it's unbelievable
but here's the thing laura peter desanc
is not a disinterested party
he's not just looking for the truth he
was the
funder of the research in wuhan so he
has a self-interest in not revealing
this
because it turns out the lab the virus
came from the lab
that's my point too this is a big deal
so any investigation going forward
it can't include peter tony fauci can't
include peter desant
because they were the ones who funded
the lab they have a conflict of interest
with coming to the truth
uh we want to ask one more more question
which is about the timing
of the lift of the moratorium
on this type of research senator in in
january of 9th
of of 2017 uh the niad
released this statement saying
we have gone through the reviews
basically we have all these
recommendations as to why this type of
research
should be permitted it was 11 days
before donald trump is inaugurated
and it's it's like a four or five page
uh memorandum
do you find that timing to be
interesting
absolutely so the nih realized that gain
of function was dangerous they ban it
for three years
and then right before donald trump
becomes president they allow it again
they start granting exemptions all
approved by dr
fauci the committee's secret they won't
let you know everybody on the committee
but you know dr
fauci knows who's on the committee and
reviews this stuff but then they also
allowed some of the research in wuhan
not to go before the committee and when
they were asked why was this not
reviewed by this committee on safety
they said well it wasn't gain of
function research so they basically
defined it out of the purview
of the committee that was supposed to be
assessing safety and preventing
you know dangerous experiments from
going on so yeah there's
there's something rotten in denmark and
somebody needs to get to the bottom of
this
but it can't include tony fauci
investigating himself
it's got to be an independent bipartisan
commission senator
do you have any faith that a bipartisan
commission given
the lies that have been put out there uh
500 000 dead and
people are just looking the other way
yeah we can't even get a hearing but
realize what they were studying
in that lab they've admitted to was 15
times more deadly than the virus we're
dealing with
covid 19 has about a 1 mortality and
that's a lot of people
but sars the one from 2004 has a 15
mortality and they were taking sars and
juicing it up and making it more
infectious
to human airway sales that's a really
scary thing to do
particularly for the chinese communists
who i don't think are the most
trustworthy of partners
yeah well and at least partly funded by
the u.s taxpayers
that is a scandal senator thank you so
much for joining us tonight
thanks laura hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else